este hospital en jartum casi en ruinas
sufrió un ataque aéreo presuntamente el
ejército sudanés
es la escena más reciente de una
encarnizada lucha por el poder entre el
grupo paramilitar fuerzas de apoyo
rápido y el ejército regular que ya
cumple un mes la violencia especialmente
en las principales ciudades de Sudán ha
dejado una crisis humanitaria que
preocupa a la comunidad internacional
la mayoría de los hospitales están fuera
de servicio las tiendas de comida
desabastecidas y los civiles abarrotados
tratando de huir la ONU estima que hay
700.000 desplazados internos y otras
200.000 personas han refugiado en países
vecinos Incluso en Sudán del sur país
que se independizó de jartum en 2011 al
oeste en Chad la situación humanitaria
de los refugiados sudaneses es crítica
cerca de 400.000 ciudadanenses ya
estaban refugiados aquí por los
conflictos de años anteriores
la ayuda humanitaria no alcanza
la ONU las organizaciones humanitarias y
nuestros socios se enfrentan a un
déficit de financiación de 1500 millones
de dólares
los continuos combates y las frágiles
treguas no han permitido la entrega
total de alimentos y medicinas los
convoyes son atacados Mientras tanto en
jeda las delegaciones de Abel fatal y
Mohamed hamman dagalo negocian un
posible al fuego con la mediación de
Arabia Saudita y Estados Unidos pero sin
éxito en terreno